c'est un mec est long dans un bistrot il
fait bon jour monsieur sait combien le
coca le petit buffet ses seins qu il
fait très bien de l'est - coca
l'obamanie fait de l'émoi 10 euros c'est
ce qu'on va voir lui dit que c'est 5
euros
fessé 5 drôle cocasse un coran le
service adacore ben voilà 10 euros et le
barman lui rend 5 euros il fait beaucoup
moins des sacrifices que j'ai pas de
coca c'est une femme c'est son
anniversaire elle va absolument un
perroquet elle fait tout les percutent y
ait du monde de paris de la banlieue de
tout être pas de perroquets elle est
très très triste elle veut s'acheter un
perroquet c'est très important pour elle
tout ça et finalement rentrant chez elle
passe devant un bibi horrible un vieux
perruquier qui vend des autres
perroquets elles diminueront ce jour et
mois c'est un pourrissement les mercer
c'est très important pour moi il fait
j'ai pas de perroquets il fait mais le
perroquet que je vois derrière vous là
au fond là qui a une drôle de tête
chalon madame pas celui-là pas celui-là
je peux pas vous vend super ok c'est
impossible
elle dit mais pourrait aussi parce que
madame ce perroquet très spécial il va
vous gênez il va vous poser des problème
croyez moi il va vous poser problème mv
je m'en fous je mens vous - les verts je
suis ok il dit écoutez je vous préviens
super ok il a été élevé dans un bordel
alors il a un langage assez vert
je m'en fous je m'en fous joue un
perroquet rentrent chez elles mais aux
questions sont parfois elle se change
pour elle à faire la fête avec ses
copines et à peine elle sort elle est
donc très de l'apport me perreault qui
fait et salons
tu vas faire la fête tu vas te faire
trancher elle est un peu victime sans
poils contente elle à son père auquel
sans voile revient à 4 heures du matin
là il fait de savoir comment ça s'est
passé
tu t'es fait déglinguer par convient
mais sans fouille se couche le lendemain
j'ai tellement pour un petit déjeuner
l'arrivée je vous la fais et donc je
vous la fais joueur a coulé sur mes
rosiers
on peut y aller très loin non non non je
peux passer trop à la maison oui alors
elle va elle rentre le soir tu marches
une drôle de manière
ça tu faire mal et plus luxueux de
percuter il a quand même pas dans gala
j'avais raison n'oubliez pas une
solution une recette pour qu'ils se
calment effet cyril vayssié côté j'ai
une idée je sais pas si ça va marcher je
suis pas là cette bombe de peinture
c'est une bombe à perroquet alors c'est
la peinture noire d'equidia mon mal
élevés vous rentrez vous le peigné en
noir cru elle rentre à la maison il
arrive enfin ça s'est passé
elle prend la bombe de peinture et noir
voilà il dit plus rien elle sur le soir
elle revient quatre heures du matin il
dit rien le matin il dit rien d'après
midi il dit rien au bout toujours elle
regarde faire leur espèce de petit con à
te connais tu la fermes ta gueule 1 et
l'as tu l'as dit fais quand je dis on se
moque je crois beaucoup
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
copains qui se sont pas vu depuis très
très longtemps et se croisent effet
écoute
franchement on va pas se quitter comme
ça hein vient à la maison tu vas manger
ça me fait tellement plaisir que moi ça
fait très longtemps que je t'ai pas vu
le tipi rentrer à la maison et fait mon
amour ma perle ma beauté j'ai amené
invités s'installent
elle amène l'apéritif mais mme à
merveille cet apéritif
mais quel kiff ça il devient je suis en
forme aujourd'hui
mais quel kiff cet apéritif comme c'est
beau elle amène les entrées mais la
mousse au chocolat
aucun d'anniversaire collègues ce plat
de résistance
mais ma tour eiffel ne triomphe pas
ferrari comme il est bon ce roselyne lot
il n'en peut plus il va le tuer avant dé
la femme elle s'en va il fait 10 mois ça
fait quand même pas me suis marié il
fait moi ça fait 25 ans et 10 mois au
bout de 25 ans de mariage tu l'appelles
encore ma merveille et m'appellent maman
tu fais tu as rien compris j'ai oublié
son prénom
[Applaudissements]
c'est parce que comme vous m'avez
remonter à bittou m'avait aussi au monde
et les couilles je fais l'amour avec ma
femme mes couilles et ça me fait malouda
mais ça éveille je comprends je
comprends cela comprend écoutez écoutez
j'ai bien une idée je sais pas si ça
coûte du pognon mais je avec vous donc
normalement faire je vais en enfer
l'été on peut vous laisser l'habitat
vous descendez géante en 2000 fois qu'on
dit allons-y
je fonce vers valence et comment
extraordinaire octobre c'est
extraordinaire mais alors là on s'éclate
on change de position
on va dans tous les sens mais gauche
icônes plus j'ai bu l'eau couilles c'est
une merveille si une paire veille fait
bravo c'est bien juste bien dû
redescendre les avait rapprochés du
trouble je joue schiste
[Rires]
sebrab en fait non c'est intime il vend
des vélos et va nous poser un gardien la
table est rempli de nourriture ya à
manger pour qu'il forme une personne
c'est ce qu'ils regardent aussi riche
c'est tout préparé didier quelle
merveille mais quelle merveille
mais quelle merveille de femmes que j'ai
mais tu vois ma mère comme c'est le
couscous est ce que tu veux comme tu as
un grain de riz amer kaze jyuni boulette
elle n'est pas des boulettes comme ça et
elle offrait dubroca et andrew bynum 16
walid à l'intérieur sa femme l art
minutieux et déjà elle a envie de tuer
la mairie
elles ont peu plus c'est tous les jours
noël on y avait une fuite
le soir ils rentrent elle a réparé la
fuite tout seul avec des clés à molette
et tout est dit quelle merveille ma
chérie mais ma mère portait ça là bas
alors il n'en peut plus et lambeaux bull
elle va voir un texto log et le système
guidé écoutez madame il ya un endroit où
ta mère elle peut pas intervenir
tu es la chambre la chambre il est
imbattable
alors mettez le paquet est comme ça ça
fait rêver il arrive le soir elle a mis
une chemise de nuit on tâte un noir est
l'ami débat magnifique noir des borgia
tel noir les draps en satin noir
la robe de chambre il
à voir tout en noir comme ça tu dis
pourquoi tout noir il est arrivé quelque
chose là ma mère
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]